hi everyone uh welcome to week three
I hope everyone had a great weekend
um so today we'll be talking about
non-parametric future learning uh but
before we talk about that a few
logistics for the class uh first on
Wednesday homework one is due so
hopefully you've been able to make some
progress on that and then we'll also
release homework too on Wednesday
on Wednesday the project surveys also
due this isn't binding but really the
goal of this is for us to get a sense
for who your groups are so that we can
assign a TA as a project Mentor or a
point of contact and that ta will
essentially be the person that can help
you out with
I answer how about answer questions that
sort of stuff and kind of by default you
should be going to your ta mentor's
office hours once you get assigned a TA
Mentor if you don't fill out the project
survey then we won't assign you a TA
Mentor until you submit the project
proposal
um on Thursday this week we also have a
tutorial on variational inference and
the goal of this tutorial is to
help potentially prepare for Monday's
lecture next week which will be on kind
of advanced Bayesian meta learning
methods uh and if you're already
familiar with with variational imprints
then uh you shouldn't feel like you need
to go uh but I think that it should be
helpful for understanding Monday's
lecture
um and money's lecture is one that will
dive a little bit deeper than some of
the other lectures uh but I think that
uh it will also in some ways give you a
better understanding of meta learning
algorithms
um and then next week uh the project
proposal is due on Wednesday
um and so you should be starting to
think about what you're doing for your
final project
um and in general these proposals are
really they're graded very lightly
really the goal
um of the project proposal is to help
you kind of have a milestone for
understanding what your project is going
to be
um and so really these are just for your
own benefit and the grading is also for
your own benefit to help us give you
feedback on your project proposal
um and then also next week there'll be a
tutorial on value-based RL which will
help prepare for some of the RL topics
that we're getting into next week
any logistical questions
Okay cool so the plan for today
um we're gonna be covering a class of
methods called non-parametric fee shot
learning methods these methods are
actually like work super well in
practice uh at least for supervised
learning problems and so they are uh
quite useful uh we'll also talk about a
case study of using these methods in
actual kind of a real world deployment
of meta learning which is pretty cool
um then we'll summarize the different
metal learning algorithms that we've
covered so far including non-parametric
methods and discuss their pros and cons
and then I'll end just by giving a few
examples of some more meta learning
applications
um and and how these algorithms have
been used in practice
the goals by the end of the lecture are
to kind of forget the basics of
non-parametric few shot learning and how
to implement them and you will be
implementing them within homework too
also trade-offs between the different
metal learning approaches and then
familiarity with kind of more applied
formulations of meta learning and how
you can take a problem and formulate it
uh within the context of metal learning
okay
um so before we dive into non-parametric
methods uh just a quick recap of what we
covered last week we talked about first
black box meta learning methods which
essentially take have a neural network
that take as input a training data set
and output some parameters or output
some sufficient statistics and then
those parameters are used to classify
new data points
so really the key idea is to parametrize
a learner as a neural network where this
learner is going to be taking in data
points directly
uh this was great in the sense that it's
a very expressive process you could
represent many learning procedures and
the downside is that it's a fairly
challenging optimization problem and
this might be something that you're
finding in homework one
okay and then we also talked about
optimization-based meta learning and
instead of representing the learning
process as a black box neural network we
instead represented it as an
optimization process where we metal
learn the free parameters of that
optimization process
and so one instantiation of this is you
embed gradient descent into the inner
learning process
and the benefit of this is that you get
the structure of optimization embedded
inside the metal learner and the
weaknesses that it typically requires
some sort of second order optimization
now one thing that I like to emphasize
in both of these approaches is that
really the only thing that you're
optimizing per se in both Black Box
Better Learning and an
optimization-based meta learning is the
parameters Theta in some ways Phi I just
kind of an intermediate byproduct of
this meta learning process and it's not
being actually optimized
um as part of metal learning it's
something that you're essentially
inferring at test time in order to solve
the task
okay
um any questions on on this kind of
material from last week before we move
on
okay so these optimization-based
approaches typically require some form
of second order optimization which makes
them
uh
they was one of the simply the main
downsides of these approaches and so
today essentially we want to be able to
embed a learning procedure and get the
structure of an existing learning
procedure without requiring a second
order optimization
and so this is the really the the
motivation behind non-parametric methods
and essentially so far we've been
learning a non-parametric we've been
using non-parametric models we've been
using models that have parametrized by
Phi I as the kind of ultimate product of
the learning procedure
um however in low data regimes
non-parametric methods actually work
pretty well and they're quite simple
so for example uh nearest neighbors is
one possible non-parametric learning
procedure where you don't actually
necessarily have any parameters you are
trying to compare examples to the
nearest Training data point and output
the corresponding label
this gets really expensive we do have a
ton of data points but when you have a
small number of data points you can
simply compare the example that you have
to all your training databikes
and so for this class of metal learning
methods
um we can notice that at met a test time
we are in this low data regime
oftentimes when we have a few examples
of small training data set
that said during better training time we
still want to be parametric because we
will hopefully have a large number a
large amount of data that we can use for
The Meta training process
and so the idea here is can we learn can
we use parametric by Learners that
produce effective non-parametric
learners
okay um it's also worth mentioning that
some of these methods in terms of when
they're introduced actually precede uh
the the purchase that we've covered so
far
okay so what exactly do I mean by using
a parametric metal learner to produce a
non-parametric learner
so let's think about nearest neighbors
as our non-parametric learner
and what it's going to look like is if
we have a training data set at test time
and a test data point
we're just going to compare the test
data point to each of the training
examples so we'll run a comparison
between each of these and we'll find the
one that is closest to our Target image
and output output the label over the
corresponding image
so we're just going to be comparing the
test data point with our trading images
now an important question is well in
what space should you compare
between the test image and the trading
images
um one really naive option that you
could do is to use L2 distance in pixel
space
um however this turns out to be actually
a really bad metric so
um if for example you take say the image
on the right is your test example and
the two images on the left are what
you're comparing against
uh if you compared to these two images
nearest neighbors are sorry L2 distance
and pixel space will actually tell you
that the image on the left is closer
than the image on the right
um so this illustrates essentially why
LT distance can be really terrible in
image space it can also be terrible in
other spaces as well
uh so we probably shouldn't use LT
distance in pixel space
uh does anyone have any ideas that for
distance metrics that we might use
instead yeah
we've used features from a model trained
on imagenet
and the other ideas
yeah
you could also use a model that was
trained as a self-supervised way instead
of instead of Industries to the
supervisor any other thoughts
so you try to do some sort of
contrastive learning that essentially
pulls together images that have a
similar label and pushes apart images
that have a different label and you can
do this either in a labeled setting it's
fairly easy to do this you could also do
it in an unlabel setting potentially if
you have
um if you make certain assumptions
um so all these all these are kind of
examples of actually trying to learn a
distance metric in various ways
and
the key idea behind kind of
non-parametric flu shot learning methods
are is to actually learn a metric like
this except learn a metric in a way that
is explicitly optimizing for good
performance at this meta test task
and so we want to essentially use the
metatrading data to learn how to compare
images
now something a really simple way to do
this is very similar to like a
contrastive technique where essentially
what we'll do is we'll just train a
network to take his input to images and
output one of those images are the same
class or not
and so if these are different classes
you try not to Output a zero if they are
images of the same class like they're
both images of voles you turn it to
Output a one
and so on and so forth you essentially
pass in these pairs of images and train
it to Output whether or not they're the
same label
and this is essentially going to look a
lot like a contrastive learning approach
um great so this is essentially the the
basics of a non-parametric metal
learning method
um this is referred to as Siamese neural
networks
and then once you train a network like
this that tells you whether two images
are from the same class
then at metatest time you simply compare
x-test to each of the images in your
training data set
um and output the label corresponding to
the one that you're most confident is
the same class
so the question is like is essentially
does non-parametric mean that we're not
using any parameters at at we're not
like kind of creating a classifier with
parameters at meta test time we're just
but we're still using parameters in in
this process and that's exactly right
trading the Siamese Network directly
corresponds to The Meta training process
essentially
and then at a test time you deploy that
classifier to run all these comparisons
um so that you're asking it assumes that
we have the same label space between
trading and testing yeah so
this is specific to classification
and it's assuming that you're going to
be doing
um some End Way classification problem
at metatest time and that your
meditating data is labeled with class
labels
oh that's a good question so do the
metatest classes have to have the same
class labels as what you saw during
metatrading
and
it doesn't actually have to have the
same class labels so this is actually a
binary classification problem right here
and it's just telling you whether or not
they're the same class and so if you
then give it images of new classes of
images from entirely new classes that
weren't seen during training the
classifier should still be able to
generalize and tell you whether or not
they're the same class
and so you don't have to have the same
class labels during meta training and
meta test time
great so this is like v0 of
non-parametric hue shot learning
techniques
and at meditating time you're doing this
binary classification and at meta test
time you're doing an end way
classification by running these pairwise
queries or comparisons okay
yeah so I should I should clarify the
you're comparing it to each image of the
support center the training set of your
test task
and this is separate from your meta
training data so you'll use all of the
training tasks all the kind of meta
training tasks that you have to train
this binary classifier and then at test
time you'll be given a new task and a
small amount of images of training
images for that new task from new
classes and
um it'll be running comparisons on those
that small amount of labeled data
yeah
so the question is um does this get very
expensive if you have a very large
support set of your test task a very
large training data set for your
testoster and yes it does get very
expensive it will increase linearly as
the size of your your training site
grows in few shot learning scenarios
where we only have a few training
examples at test time
um it's still very practical to run but
if you have if you want to learn a task
that has a large amount of training data
per task this might not be the the best
approach
yeah for your suggested life I guess
right we don't have any tasks maybe just
a bunch of fair depends images
yeah exactly so
um I guess the the question is there
isn't actually any explicit task
structure during The Meta training
process
um and that's that's right we'll
actually see in the next approach that
we'll actually leverage the task
structure more explicitly but here
you're actually kind of breaking down
the task structure and just using the
classification labels
yeah
um
good question so what if you um had more
than one example per class uh you had
two shots per class for example
um does that give you any advantage
um so I guess does anyone have any
thoughts on this question
closer
expected test performance
before I don't think it's similar to
breaking down
every train you've been training data
set in the past is different labels
the lion will never appears
still have
uh
there's two things here um in terms of
the task structure you're essentially
making the tasks to be binary
classification tasks during meta
training um so there is sort of that
structure and that there you have a
binary classification task but going
back to the the number of shots
questioned where you have multiple data
points
um there are a few different ways that
you can handle this the naive way to
handle it is just to treat the shots
independently from one another and you
still do get a benefit from having
multiple shots in that case because if
it's closer to one of them than the
other for example then
um then it will actually still output
that label
um and so you still do get benefits from
having multiple shots even if you treat
them independently that said there are
are better ways to to handle multiple
shots that we'll handle in the next
couple slides
foreign
so one thing that you might notice here
is that meta training and metatest time
they're doing different things and
one of the things we saw in the previous
lectures we often want to kind of match
what we're doing what we're training for
I'm at a training time and what we're
ultimately going to be doing at meta
test time
and so
we want to create a procedure that
actually matches what happens at
meditating and meta test time
now the way that we can do this is um
instead of doing binary classification
during meta training we can actually do
endway classification doing nearest
Neighbors in some learned embedding
space
and what this will look like is is this
diagram right here where each of our
training examples say we're doing
four-way classification each of our tiny
examples are here we compute an
embedding for each of those four
examples
and then we do nearest neighbors with
our test example in a differentiable way
such that we output the
um I'll put the label corresponding to
the thing that we're closest to so in
this case maybe it decides that the
weight for this example is the highest
tensible output essentially a soft Max
distribution over over those weights
and so particularly mathematically what
this looks like is we will
compute embeddings for each of the
examples and then we'll compare them
um using essentially this network we're
essentially going to be Computing the
similarity between each of the training
examples and our test example
um we'll look at each of the
uh the label for each of those
corresponding training examples
and then we will
um
have y test correspond to this
this dot product between the weights and
the corresponding labels
um in terms of the architecture there's
a number of details that you can do here
um
this architecture uses a convolutional
encoder for the images it also uses a
bi-directional LCM so that the
embeddings of each example doesn't just
depend on the example itself but also
depends on the other examples but those
are essentially more sophisticated
choices that you can do
but really the key idea here is that if
we train this end to end then we can
actually train for
nearest Neighbors in NY classification
to give you the right answer rather than
training for this kind of the the buy me
the binary classifier on the previous
slide
yeah so um it essentially looks a lot
like attention attention is essentially
just a DOT product it's like a really
fancy way to say that we're going to be
doing Dot products and you can see it
like essentially
um what looks a lot like a DOT product
right there where we're going to be
Computing this similarity metric between
the test example and each of the
training examples and then according to
that equation there
taking that similarity function
multiplying it by the label and then
summing to get a distribution over
labels
[Music]
the first one
once yeah that's a great question
so essentially the um
the question is that if you have some
classes that are more fine-grained than
others
then the Siamese classifier it doesn't
necessarily know for a given class if
it's like a very fine brain class or not
not a very fine-grained class and then
when you do comparisons only pairwise it
has to essentially guess how
fine-grained the classes or not
but in this case you're actually passing
in the entire like all of the classes
into the network and this allows the
network to actually look at what the
other classes look like realize that
they're breeds of dogs and not dogs for
example like dogs versus cats and use
that to determine how fine-grained of a
comparison it wants to do
um and so I looking at the entire like
all of the classes in the problem
actually allows it to tailor how um how
narrowly it will be defining a class
yeah
um
so I think the question is that what if
it's not images what if these are low
dimensional data points yeah so
certainly um you can essentially
this is an image classification example
but you can also do other classification
problems where
uh this corresponds to like text or
maybe it corresponds to tabular data or
something like that and you probably
wouldn't use a convolutional network if
it's um like tabular data or something
like that but you can use the same sort
of idea
um and uh yeah the main ideas will still
apply
[Music]
yeah that's a great question they used
an lstm here and it does actually impose
some form of ordering which isn't a
great design Choice it would probably be
better to use an encoder that doesn't
actually depend on the order like
attention and so forth this was back in
2016 and so things like Transformers
weren't as popular back then or I think
the Transformer officially didn't really
exist back then
um and lstms were one of the more
popular things to operate on sets but it
does impose an ordering and there are
probably other architectures that could
try to take into account all of the
information of the training data points
without imposing and ordering
possible
so the question is like what if you take
a lot of classes at trading time and
then fewer classes at test time yeah
yeah so one of the things that's
important here is if if you want to be
able to generalize to New Image classes
that aren't in your set the set of
things that you saw previously then if
you just traded like a thousand way
classifier or something you see a new
image cost it's not necessarily going to
actually correspond to any of those
thousand things and the classifier may
do
unexpected things in that case because
it's sort of like an undefined behavior
um that said you can still use the
embedding of a like a supervised
classifier and do like nearest Neighbors
in that embedding
um and that that that kind of approaches
more resembles these kind of meta
learning approaches here
um and then of course if the test
classes that you have are lie within the
kind of classes that you see during
training that it definitely makes sense
to use supervised learning rather than
to use Better Learning it's really when
you have new classes
yeah
that we made
last week because
yeah so the question is um when we
introduce new classes are we violating
this kind of assumption that the
training and test tasks come from the
same distribution
um it's a little bit difficult to say
actually
um in some ways as long as the classes
themselves are coming from the same
distribution and you have enough
training classes then you should be
fine you should be able to generalize to
new classes it becomes more of a problem
if you have a small number of classes
because uh
then it's like less clear what is what
is in distribution or not
okay
um so one of the things you can know
here is unlike the Siamese networks
Mediterranean time and meta test time
match so we're doing endway
classification both during meta training
and during meta testing
okay um so in terms of the algorithm we
can take the algorithm that uh that we
learned before from the Black Box
approach where we sample tasks sample
data sets and then learn from those
learn from the training data
um and what changes is is these two
steps right here so instead of
um instead of computing some parameters
for solving that task
we're instead going to be Computing
labels according to uh
nearest Neighbors in some embedding
space
and uh as we kind of talked about very
briefly because
we're essentially integrating out these
parameters if either we're not actually
representing Phi directly this is why
it's referred to as a non-parametric
approach is that we don't have
parameters
um and then in terms of actually uh
updating in the middle learning process
we update the parameters of our
embedding function such that the
nearest neighbors process produces the
correct answer
cool
so from there yeah
um so it's something in the sense that
usually your classifier outputs like a
distribution over classes and then you'd
use like across entropy loss or
something compared to compare the
distributions in terms of actually
predicting the label
um I guess I should maybe represent that
as like a p over over y test rather than
y test directly
um and then yeah in terms of practice
you're actually using this you would
actually take the arc Max rather than
Okay cool so now one last thing is one
thing that came up before is like what
if you have more than one shot or more
than one training example
um and both of the previous approaches
we were treating
each example from a class completely
independently and so if we had like five
examples from the same class we would
just be comparing to each of those five
images and not doing any sort of kind of
aggregation of the information
and so one last thing that we can do to
make this approach better is instead of
Performing comparisons independently to
all of the examples within a class you
can actually try to aggregate class
information into a single embedding of
that particular class
um and so this is essentially what that
looks like is instead of doing
comparisons to all of these green data
points and all the blue data points and
all the orange data points independently
what you'll try to do is aggregate in
some embedding Space by just averaging
the embeddings of those of those
examples and then take the nearest
neighbors to the the kind of class
embeddings rather than the example
embeddings
um so in some ways this looks a little
bit like k-means in a sense it's not
actually an unsupervised procedure it's
still kind of a Mediterranean procedure
but we're going to be Computing these
prototypes or these kind of cluster
centers and uh then comparing to those
prototypes
um and so mathematically what this looks
like is we
um we'll be Computing these prototypes
which are just taking all of the
examples for a particular class and
averaging the embedding of that class
and then once we have these prototypes
we will then do
um we'll kind of compare using some
distance function it could be by
multiplication it could be like an L2
distance function or something like that
and then we could exponentiate and
normalize to get a distribution
and so D here corresponds to it could be
euclidean distance or cosine distance
well measuring the distance between
f of x which is the white dot to each of
the C's
um and then
comparing the distances between the two
different classes
okay
yeah
yeah so the question is like in some
cases maybe your classes are somewhat
heterogeneous like maybe you have
different breeds of dogs and you maybe
you shouldn't actually aggregate by
averaging
um or have maybe you shouldn't have a
single prototype per class
um
there's kind of a couple a couple
answers here
um
I guess the first answer is that in some
cases it may not actually be a good idea
to have a single prototype and I'll
mention it approach in a couple slides
that actually has multiple prototypes
per class
uh and the second answer is that
um
these embeddings are learned and they're
high dimensional and
what the network can do is it can learn
a representation that tries to kind of
really get the essence of a dog for
example and collapse out things that
aren't that don't correspond to a dog
um
and potentially learn a representation
space in which like the variants of dogs
are invariant
um
and so even in cases where you have
heterogeneous classes oftentimes this
approach still works pretty well
um especially if you give the embedding
flexibility um that said I all mentioned
approach that doesn't do that
yeah I guess
because I'm always find pictures
more than actually a classic
yeah essentially I guess what I meant by
um dog is that you essentially want to
it to be invariant to things that are
class agnostic and uh and push together
things that are kind of representative
of the class
um it could be dog features I mean in
general it should be like more like
textural more General things than
something specifically on with respect
to a dog so that you can generalize to
new classes
foreign
so
um
to summarize these non-parametric
methods we saw three versions of it
Siamese networks matching networks and
prototypical networks this is
essentially the evolution of these
methods and I think that
um prototypical networks is probably
um
it is somewhat in my opinion it's at
least one of the kind of methods that
keeps all the Simplicity of these
methods and it also works very well I
think that it's probably the best of
these approaches and it's also one of
the simplest methods
um essentially all these approaches
correspond to doing some form of
embedding and and then doing nearest
Neighbors in that embedding space
um they just do this in in slightly
different ways
um and so one challenge that does come
up is that you might need to reason
about more complex representations or
relationships between data points and so
there are approaches that are a little
bit more complex than these methods but
that try to address more challenging few
shot learning problems
um so for example one thing that you
could do is instead of
um using like cosine distance or instead
of using the euclidean distance what you
can do is you could actually try to
learn a distance function and so
essentially what this approach is doing
is it's learning these features just
like in prototypical that works but also
simply learning a distance function
between classes rather than using a
fixed distance function
another approach like I've mentioned
before is to learn kind of a mixture of
prototypes rather than just a single
prototype per class
and then lastly another complex approach
that you get more complex approach that
you can do is to try to do some sort of
message passing
um
on the embeddings rather than just doing
a simple comparison
cool so that's a summary of
non-parametric methods
um
are there any more questions before I go
through a case study
cool okay so
um in last year's version of the course
I went through a case study that was
looking at Dermatological image
classification I just wanted to briefly
mention it because it's a pretty cool
paper
um and if you're interested in things
related to like Medical Imaging or
diagnosis and that sort of thing
um or long tail distributions this is a
cool paper
um and it kind of adapted prototypical
networks to this particular problem
um the case study that I want to go
through this year is um is actually a
project that we worked on earlier this
year where we actually deployed the
algorithm to uh kind of in a live
application which I think is uh not
always
um maybe more rare in terms of things
that are uh so on the edge of research
okay
um so the problem that we have here is
that we want to give feedback to
students
and as a very concrete example
um there Stanford offered this free
intro to CS course
to more than 12 000 students
and we want to be able to give feedback
to the students on a diagnostic exam
that they took in the course
and their submissions corresponded to
open-ended python code
and we estimated that it would take
about eight months of human labor to
give feedback to all of the students in
the course
and this isn't just a problem for this
particular course this is really a
problem for any sort of like online
education where we want to scale
feedback to large numbers of students
um specifically what the problem looks
like is we have some python code that
the student wrote and we want to be able
to identify some misconceptions that
they had and we can frame this as a
classification problem where we are
really a multi-class binary
classification problem where we
essentially classify whether they had a
certain misconception or not
um and this is using the same rubrics
that instructors at Stanford use to get
feedback kind of like grade scope Style
rubrics
um this is a hard problem uh in general
also just a hard problem for machine
learning because it you don't have that
much annotation
um it takes a lot of expertise and a lot
of work to give feedback
these
this data ends up being very long-tailed
and that you can solve the same problem
in many different ways
and also instructors are constantly
adding assignments and solutions or
sorry editing assignments and exams and
as a result the solutions and the
questions and the feedback look very
different from year to year
okay
um so how might we frame this as a med
learning problem does anyone have any
thoughts or ideas
so you can meditate on past exams and
then what do you do at meta test time
any thoughts
yeah
um
a number of times
cool so yeah you can essentially have
different assignments be different tasks
and you can like uh meditate across that
um and then when you're given a new
assignment at meta test time what
happens then
um when you're given a new assignment
um at meta test time what happens at
that point
this one
so you could just run the algorithm
although we need to somehow adapt the
model in some way
so you can embed the code and then do
some like compare it to Common Solutions
and then where do those common Solutions
come from
or twice
yeah yeah so you can essentially have
different solution types to different
problems if you have something bad uh
I'm still thinking about it
the person behind you
um
yeah so when you have a new assignment
you can have the instructor label a few
examples and then use that as your kind
of training data set for the test
assignment
so that's essentially what it what it
will look like so
um for meditating we have uh eight exams
from
interest yes course cs106
and each student we have this is fully
labeled the students get feedback via
the rubric
um get into the details a little bit
each rubric has items and each item has
several options
and so an example of a rubric looks like
this where the misconception has to do
with string insertion and then you have
different options with respect to this
particular concept
and then what we're actually going to do
is instead of treating different
assignments as tasks we're going to
actually treat each of these rubric
option options as different tasks and so
this is a binary classification task
this is a binary classification task and
so forth
um and we'll essentially get tasks for
each one of these rubric options and
we'll have four tasks for this and then
for another rubric item we'll have some
number of additional tasks and so on and
so forth
cool and then this is the meta training
process and what we'll do is we will
use essentially prototypical networks
and our model will take his input a
sequence of python code tokens
and we'll use a stack Transformer model
to essentially take the code and embed
that into a fixed dimensional embedding
and then run prototypical networks and
then at meta test time we will have
um we'll have some solution actually a
lot of solutions we'll label a few of
them and use that to generate the
prototypes for true and for false free
for perfection
yeah
yeah
completely lose everything
we did actually complete it uh treated
completely separately there's one thing
that we did that I'll mention soon that
makes them slightly less separate but
um because like these two things can
both be true for example and so uh as a
result
uh we need to basically like do a
classification problem here and solve
this classification problem
um and I'll talk a little bit about how
we can give the model a little bit more
information yeah
important
lately
yeah so the question is does this kind
of break the IID assumption in terms of
tasks um when we sample tasks we don't
always sample like all four of these
tasks from this rubric item we
essentially sample IID from the
distribution of rubric a rubrics or of
questions and then over the distribution
of items and then over the distribution
of options and we try to sample from do
that sort of
um that sort of sampling in the
independent fashion
okay
um so this is kind of the the v0 for
what we tried for this problem
um and we found that uh actually
applying this out of the box didn't work
very well
um and that attention isn't quite all
you need to solve the problem
so um there are a couple tricks that we
found to be pretty helpful especially
because we didn't have that much meta
training data
um so the first trick was that we can
instead of only using tasks from the
metatrain data set we can augment the
rubric tasks with self-supervised tasks
so we could have a task that corresponds
to predicting
um the kind of the compilation error
that happens we can also do this sort of
mask language modeling kinds of tasks as
well
uh the second trick is to incorporate
side information into the model so if
you only have a few examples of positive
and negative examples for a particular
rubric option it can actually be
somewhat ambiguous what you're trying to
classify on and so we can give it side
information that corresponds to the name
of the rubric option as well as the text
of the question and this essentially
gives the model a little bit more
information with respect to like how
it's supposed to be giving feedback to
the student and what this rubric option
corresponds to and essentially we'll
just kind of prepend the site
information into the Transformer model
I mean so this is kind of answering the
question before about treating these
completely independently because the
decided information isn't quite as
independent
um then the last thing we found to be
super helpful is to pre-trade on
unlabeled python code and the way this
works is there are some great databases
or data sets that have a bunch of python
code and you can run a model like Bert
on that code to get some pre-trained
embeddings
and we use this we do this pre-trading
before doing the meta training process
okay um so the full model looks
something like this where we have the
code that the student wrote we also have
the question text in the rubric text we
pass all of this through a Transformer
model to get an embedding of that
solution with respect to that question
and rubric option
and then we do that for all of the
positive examples for that rubric option
and average to get an embedding for
positive as well as average across the
solutions that got it
that were negative for that particular
rubric option and then we get a
prototype both for positive and for
negative and we can compare new student
solutions to those two prototypes
okay
cool um so uh I guess when we approach
this problem we didn't actually unders
like it's a pretty difficult problem to
give feedback to students we didn't
really understand we didn't have like
super high expectations with respect to
how well it would work
um it turned out to actually work pretty
well so
using the kind of prototypical networks
outperforms a supervised learning method
by around 8 to 17 which is pretty
significant we also see that in the case
where you have a held out rubric you can
actually do better than a human TA in
terms of accuracy or precision
you're more accurate
um in the case where you haven't held
out exam entirely uh there's still room
for improvement so we're still about
eight percent worse than a human ta
um but still like 74 accuracy is uh in
my opinion actually pretty good
um and then lastly we also deployed this
model to the code in place course that I
mentioned previously
um so the students took the diagnostic
on May 10th
um we need to actually give the feedback
to the students in some way and so
and Chris designed this interface
we paired the rubric option with some
text that described the feedback for
that rubric option this text was written
by a human but the the classification
problem was done by the metal learner
um the students evaluated the feedback
we also used syntax highlighting to try
to show them where the error was
um and then lastly it's worth mentioning
that if there are syntax errors anywhere
in the code that means that you can't
really use unit testing to um to
actually give feedback to the students
and that's why having like models that
take as input the raw text or the raw
python code is pretty helpful
and so lastly in in kind of a blind
randomized trial uh
humans gave feedback on around a
thousand of the student Solutions this
is used in the support set because we
actually had a decent amount of data
here we also fine-tuned the model as
well
um and then the the model gave feedback
on the remaining 15 000 examples
and around 2 000 of them could be Auto
graded
uh and so what we found is that uh in
both cases actually the um the human the
human and the Machine learning model
we're actually giving pretty good
feedback
um the the students were agreeing with
the feedback from the model 97.9 of the
time and it was agreeing with the human
they were agreeing with the human
feedback 96.7 of the time
um now you could agree with things but
not have that those things not actually
be useful so we can also ask them if
they think it's useful and they said it
was uh they rated it as um being useful
with like a score of 4.6 out of 5.
cool
um and then last week we also checked
for kind of signs of bias by
demographics which is usually a good
thing to do with machine learning
systems and we didn't see any signs of
bias in terms of the most represented
genders and countries in the data set
oh so hopefully that gives you a sense
for how we can try to formulate problems
in the context of mud learning
um and also an example of how these
algorithms might actually be deployed in
real world scenarios
cool
um so
and that was actually also a specific
case of deploying a non-parametric
method
now let's go through some properties of
meta learning algorithms and try to
compare the different kinds of
approaches
um cool so we've talked about three
classes of approaches
and if you think about these from the
standpoint of
metal learning like having this
computation graph and optimizing that
computation graph end to end
uh we can think of Black Box models as
we essentially you all of them as a
computation graph that takes us and put
training data and a test example and
produces the corresponding label uh
Black Box methods treat the computation
graph in a like fully Black Box way
optimization-based methods embedded in a
gradient descent procedure or something
like that
um into that computation graph and then
lastly non-parametric approaches can
also be viewed as having this particular
kind of computation graph
and that computation graph is something
that embeds nearest neighbors or
something like nearest neighbors to
prototypes within that computation graph
Where We Are comparing the test example
to these prototypes and these prototypes
are computed from the training set using
the following equation
so essentially in many ways all of these
methods are
are doing the same thing it's just
different forms of computation graphs to
embed structure into the meta learning
process
now
I can also note again that you can mix
and match different components of this
and so in many ways I think that these
are really the kind of the three kind of
Base classes of approaches but there
isn't a hard line in between these kinds
of approaches uh so you can have methods
that are like sort of hybrid methods
that for example condition on the data
and also run gradient descent on the
data uh methods that
compute some embedding
um like a like the embeddings that we
see in non-parametric approaches and
then do gradient descent on that
embedding as well as approaches that do
something like mammal but initialize the
last layer uh
as prototypical networks during meta
training
um so there isn't really
um kind of the separation between these
kinds of approaches is very blurred and
there are many approaches that are like
don't cleanly fall into any one of these
three approaches
foreign
yeah so the question is um for early
approaches like RL squared which is a
meta RL algorithm that we'll talk about
in a couple lectures how would you
classify that
um Earl squirt is basically just an lstm
and so I would classify it under the the
black box approaches because it takes
its input the data and passes it through
a recurrent Network
all right
cool um so that was the kind of
computation graph perspective another
way that we can think about these
classes of approaches is their kind of
algorithmic properties and I think that
this is useful for thinking about when
you might use one approach versus
another
um so one algorithmic property that we
might want is for it to be very
expressive and what I mean by expressive
is the ability to represent a wide range
of different learning procedures
and this can be useful because
um
in some scenarios we may have a lot of
Mediterranean data and we want to learn
a very specific or a very good learning
procedure and if you want to learn a
very good procedure from a lot of data
then we should have be able to represent
many different learning procedures
um another property that we should care
about is what I'll refer to as
consistency
and what I mean by consistency is that
uh the learning procedure that you get
ideally it would monotonically improve
as you get more data or at least
monotonically improved in expectation
um and essentially this is I like to use
the term consistency because in
statistics consistency refers to as you
get more data your estimator will
converge to the true estimator and so in
this case a learning procedure a learned
learning procedure is kind of guaranteed
to be consistent if it improves
expectation as you get more and more
data converges to the the right answer
um and this is important because it
potentially reduces the Reliance on The
Meta training tasks
um and so if you don't have a lot of
meditating tasks or maybe you have a
domain shift between Mediterranean
better test time if you guarantee that
your learning procedure is consistent
then you'll at least be able to improve
as you get more data on the test task
um and so this potentially means that
you might get better OED performance
especially if you have a lot of data of
your test task
um and you can recall that that uh last
week we kind of showed these curves that
showed kind of OD performance of
different algorithms and we see a pretty
big difference between different
approaches
okay um so these two properties are
important for a lot of different
applications and if we think about these
three classes of approaches we can think
about them in terms of those properties
so Black Box methods have complete
expressive power
but they aren't guaranteed to be
consistent as you give them as you pass
more data into the recurrent neural
network it may not continue to improve
optimization approach based approaches
um are consistent because it essentially
reduces the running gradient descent at
meta test time and so in expectation you
will improve
um if you have a very deep Network it is
very expressive but you do need a fairly
large model to do that
and this is specific to supervised
learning settings when we move to RL
settings the uh the expressive power is
actually somewhat reduced
and then lastly for non-parametric
methods they are quite expressive for
for most architectures
um and under certain conditions they
they will be
um they will be consistent as you get
more data to compare to
okay
um so these are a couple different ways
of thinking about these algorithms
um there are some other pros and cons as
well that I'll go through so Black Box
methods are easy to combine with a
variety of different learning problems
but it leads to a challenging
optimization and is often data
inefficient for optimization-based
approaches we also talked about how this
has a kind of positive inductive bias at
the start of metal learning which means
that it can be easier to optimize it
also handles very enlarged K pretty well
um you can run gradient descent even
with a very large amount of data
and it's model agnostic uh the downside
is that you get the second order
optimization and this can mean that it
can be compute and memory intensive if
you have a very large optimization
process
um and then for non-parametric methods
one thing that's quite nice about them
is that unlike something that's doing a
gradient descent in the inner loop it's
an entirely feed forward process like
doing nearest neighbors for example is
is entirely feed forward
and this means that they are usually
computationally very fast and also
pretty easy to optimize
um in practice people have found that
these algorithms sometimes don't
generalize well to varying K and of
course they don't scale well to very
large K because you need to do K
comparisons or n times K comparisons
and then lastly so far these methods are
limited to classification so overall I
think that if you have a classification
problem this class of methods is really
great if you have a regression problem
for example these approaches are less
applicable
um and then lastly I think that
well-tuned versions of these approaches
generally perform fairly comparably on a
lot of the few shot learning benchmarks
I think that this likely says more about
the benchmarks than the methods
themselves
um and ultimately what you end up using
will probably depend on your use case
um but hopefully this gives you a sense
for the kinds of things you should be
thinking about when deciding which
method to use
I think
yeah it's a good question I think this
is more of an empirical observation than
um
than anything kind of theoretically
about them I think that it may have to
do with like in prototypical networks
for example like averaging a lot of
things maybe
um
maybe difficult especially if those
different things are somewhat
heterogeneous like in different parts of
the space then averaging them may lead
to kind of weird behavior
um that's some of my intuition but uh
I'm not sure if that's exactly what's
going on or causing them to to have less
performance when you have varying okay
yeah
um
yes you're asking like what are examples
of regression problems in Middle
learning yeah
so we'll go through a couple
of them at the very end but some
examples are things like pose prediction
like predicting the orientation of
objects
um if you like want to control a robot
and it has continuous action spaces
um one other example that we had in the
mammal paper that I think is a nice toy
example for playing with algorithms is
one where different tasks correspond to
different sinusoid curves and you want
to predict like the
um if you aren't predict essentially the
the value of the sinusoid curve for a
particular input this is actually a nice
toy problem especially if you want to
like try out new approaches and so forth
um
those are some examples I mean I think
that there's yeah there's also like a
lot of machine learning problems in
general that that are have more
continuous output spaces as well
okay um and then one other kind of
property that I'll mention is what I'll
refer to as uncertainty awareness
um and in particular if you have a very
small number of examples it may be it
may be that your task isn't actually
like fully defined in some ways it may
actually be unclear what the correct
behavior is and it's nice if our
algorithms can reason about that
ambiguity and tell us when they aren't
sure about the task
um
versus just trying to guess something
without saying whether they're unsure or
not
um this is something that's useful in
machine learning in general
um and uh it's also useful in settings
where you want to do some form of active
learning where the algorithm should ask
for more data for example or maybe you
want to get calibrated on certain
estimates or maybe in reinforcement
learning you want to be able to
efficiently explore the space and find
parts of the state space that will help
you reduce ambiguity
um and also I guess
um it's nice to derive approaches that
are kind of based on like Bayesian
inference and stuff like that uh and uh
and it can be somewhat satisfying to
kind of explain the framework within the
context of
um that kind of language
um and so we'll essentially discuss
um
this a lot on Monday next week
and uh it's not just going to be about
having algorithms reason about ambiguity
it's also going to be about deriving
these algorithms and thinking about
different tasks from the standpoint of
kind of Bayesian graphical models
cool
um any questions on the algorithms
before I move on to some applications
[Music]
you're asking are these properties
yeah so I think this is consistent under
certain conditions
um yeah so it's gonna have to do with
the model structure
if your data is drawn IID then I think
that you're you're set but if your model
structure for example
like collapses down information like
essentially if you're embedding discards
information about the image
um or discards important information
about the image then you'll no longer be
consistent because as you get more data
even if you get more and more data there
might be parts of that embedding space
that are just like that should be there
but aren't in that embedding space
um yeah so that's that's it's
essentially about the kind of the kind
of representation that it ends up
learning
so the question is are non-parametric
method is the most robust to domain
shift
um I think that actually optimization
based on non-parametric
both tend to be a lot more robust than
Black Box methods I haven't seen any
kind of detailed empirical analysis on
which of the two tend to be more robust
if I were to guess I would think that
non-parametric methods are slightly more
robust
just because they're simpler to train
and things that are kind of simpler to
train often
um might kind of overfit a little bit
less to the meditating data
cool
um so now let's run through a couple
more applications
um I'll grow through these pretty
quickly but these should just give you a
sense for some of the different ways
that people have applied metal learning
and will also end on a note that I think
is a more General note that I think is
useful for thinking about new kinds of
applications
um so one application in the domain of
Robotics is uh say we want a robot to be
able to place an object into a container
and we want to be able to place it into
a container even for containers and
objects that it hasn't seen before
what we can do is we can give it
demonstrations of placing objects into
containers for a wide variety of objects
and then at by the test time our
training data will be a video of a human
placing into a particular container and
um
are query data or our test data for each
task will correspond to a teleoperated
demonstration of of solving that task
um and this is going to be an
optimization based model and it's going
to correspond to mammal with a learned
inner loss function and what you get is
something like this where at metatest
time you give it a video of placing an
object into a new container
and then the robot adapts its policy
using that video of a human and then
gets a policy that acts like this
and as long as you have uh each task
essentially corresponds to dropping this
task corresponds to dropping in the Red
Bull for different positions of the the
objects and the distractors
um another example is uh predicting the
properties of different molecules this
is potentially useful in drug Discovery
problems
different tasks correspond to Breaking
properties and activities of different
molecules and D train and detest will
correspond to different instances of
those molecules
in this case they use optimization-based
approaches and they compared three
different approaches which is mammal
first order mammal and almost no inner
loop which essentially just as mammal on
the last layer of the model
I'm going to use the a graph a gated
graph neural network as the base model
with mammal
and what they found is that if you do
like things like K nearest neighbors or
fine-tuning on top of a model that
doesn't perform as well as using meta
training on the the molecules they had
another example this is a regression
example like the first robotics example
you want to be able to predict human
motion into the future
and different tasks are going to
correspond to different human users and
different kinds of motions
and D train will correspond to the path
K time steps of motion and D test will
correspond to the kind of future
time steps of motion
um they use in they use a kind of a
hybrid of an optimization based approach
and a black box approach
and um in particular they use mammal
with this additional learned update Rule
and their base model was a recurrent
neural network because it needs to take
his input the time the previous time
steps of motion
this is kind of what um their model
looks like whereas it kind of is
adapting to the previous time steps of
motion and then predicting the blue
figures into the future
um and then here here's kind of a
snapshot of the results which they find
that kind of doing some form of transfer
learning or learning from scratch
doesn't perform as well as their um
their meta learning process
yeah
um
yeah so the um
this is a kind of a more advanced
example and essentially what it looks
like is um
the one thing that you might notice is
that the training set and the test set
are actually a little bit different
um
one thing that you could do instead of
having to be a video of a human is just
use a teleoperated demonstration
and in that case you can just use an
imitation learning loss as your as your
inner learning objective
um and so
kind of what that would look like is
something like for your optimizing for
the parameters of your policy such that
the
um
this is your your outer loss function
this is your inner loss function
this is your training demo and then
you also have
your test demo
this is over all of your trading tasks
and so what you can do is if you have a
kind of bolted demo in the Inner Loop in
the outer loop then you can use like an
imitation learning loss function which
essentially just corresponds to like
something like mean squared error
between the true action and the
predicted action
for a given state
now
if this is like a video of a human then
you don't actually have the actions
um and so one cool thing that you could
do is instead of having this be like an
imitation learning loss function uh what
we do instead is we actually learn a
loss function
and
um
the
let me I think so we actually have like
parameters in this loss function and we
meditate both the initialization as well
as the parameters of this loss function
okay
cool um and so if you're in scenarios
where you actually don't have good label
signal in your trading set you can
actually do something like this
cool so we looked at the human motion
prediction example
um and then one more application or
example that I'll mention is language
modeling
um and so many of you might be familiar
with gpt3 this can also be viewed as a
meta learner or a few shot learner
and here the tasks are actually pretty
diverse they have tasks like spelling
Corrections simple math problems
translated between languages and a
variety of others
um they're all represented as these
language generation problems where D
train corresponds to a sequence of
characters and detest corresponds to the
following sequence of characters
uh so for example you can give it some
examples of solving math problems and
then ask it to solve more math problems
for you you can give it examples of
correcting spelling and it will and then
ask it to correct spelling of more
things and so forth
um the model that they use is a very
large Transformer model uh and so you
can think of it essentially as a black
box metal learner
and there are some cool examples of what
it can do so you can give it uh
essentially the gray text corresponds to
D train and then the black corresponds
to the generation from the model and so
you can give it an example of a new word
that it should learn
and then ask it to use that word in a
sentence and then it can generate an
example of using that word in the
sentence
um you can also ask it to edit language
so to say like poor English and good
English give it in this case one two
three four four examples of that
um and then ask it to
um ask it to generate actually no sorry
three examples
yeah three examples up to here then give
it another poor English input and then
ask it to uh produce the corresponding
output
um here's a and here's another kind of
example of uh
of correcting the English
yeah
yeah so essentially
um the prompts here essentially
correspond to the kind of training data
for the example and um
it's essentially like a black box metal
earner where
um it's the version of a black box men
learner where you're outputting like
some hidden state or something like that
rather than outputting like a full set
of parameters
and kind of similar to the kind of Black
Box metal earners that you're
implementing in homework one
okay um and so one closing note that I'd
like to mention that we saw actually in
a lot of these examples is that D trade
and detest don't actually need to be
sampled independently from the data for
a task
and this is pretty cool because this
means that you can actually kind of
tweak The Meta training process in a lot
of different ways you could have D train
have like noisy labels and detest have
clean labels and essentially learn how
to learn from noisy labels I essentially
get an Optimizer that can learn well
from from the noisy labels uh D train
could also be like weekly supervised
kind of like this example right here
where you actually learned a loss
function
um it can also have some domain ships so
you could have
um you could try to learn from data from
a different domain such that it produces
a model that works well in some Target
domain
um and so this is what would happen
during better trading time and then at a
test time you give it
data sets that have noisy labels or weak
supervision and so forth and git models
kind of like the ones that you want
yeah
so um
right you're asking um do you need to
have training to necessarily be harder
than testing
essentially what's really important is
that the desired behavior of the model
is represented in detest because this is
what's going to be used to like actually
train the model to get some desired
Behavior and then D train should
represent the kinds of data that you're
going to give it at metatest time and so
if you want it to be able to learn from
noisy labels at meta test time then it's
good to meditate it to be able to handle
noisy labels you could also try to have
like meditate it on harder tasks like
meditate it on the ability to learn from
noisy labels and maybe that would make
it also do better at clean labels
um because it's just a harder task but
uh that wouldn't
um kind of more of what I'm trying to
convey here is you can actually do some
cool things with the metal learner that
actually trains it to be able to handle
different kinds of learning problems
cool
um so to recap what we talked about
today we talked about quite a lot of
things uh non-parametric keyshot
learning approaches which learned to do
these nearest neighbor matching queries
uh we talked about properties of meta
learning algorithms and compared
different approaches and then we also
looked at a few applications
um and then yeah to end a few reminders
homework one is due on Wednesday also
please fill out the project survey by
Wednesday
and the crowded proposals will be due
next week